hello thank you for joining us today for
the first webinar in our machine
learning series neural networks in the
Wolfram language we're so pleased to
welcome today's presenters
Sebastian bodenstein and Telus in Beynon
from our Advanced Research Group
Sebastian and Talley have been leaders
in developing the neural net framework
in the Wolfram language since the
release of version 11 Sebastian will
give us an introduction to the neural
Nets showing how to build a neural net
model and how to scale models for
training on large datasets today's
presentations will demonstrate
higher-order neural network programming
and Wolfram language 11.3 with ready to
use models from the Wolfram neural net
repository during the webinar we'll
share many online resources and links
with you and before we close tally will
provide a sneak peek at future
directions my name is Cassidy Hinkle
project manager with Wolfram research
and I will be your online host for this
machine learning webinar series I am
joined by several of my Wolfram
colleagues behind the scenes to respond
to your typed questions during the
webinar and help point you to the
resources you need feel free to submit
your questions using the control panel
on the right side of your screen you can
resize the windows to customize your
webinar experience we've had good
success with Firefox and Chrome browsers
so if you do experience any issues with
screen or audio streaming you might want
to try logging in with a different
browser today's webinar is a great
opportunity for you to learn more about
deep learning approaches to solving
problems the presentation notebooks will
be made available to you to download and
they can be resources for you to use as
you start working with and training
neural networks in the Wolfram language
we will post links to the presentation
materials in the chat pane shortly but I
want to advise you to wait to evaluate
these notebooks until after the webinar
as some neural net models take time to
build and might distract you from the
live presentations before passing the
microphone to Sebastian I'm going to
share
poll question asking about your
motivation for a participating in
today's webinar when the poll question
appears on your screen please select
your response and we'll share the
answers after everyone has a chance to
respond thanks again for joining us our
first presentation is coming up next
grace okay so this is the first of a I
think it's a three-part series so this
this will basically be an introduction
to our framework it will motivate why
your networks are interesting and it'll
also leave quite a bit of time for
questions where we can focus on other
things on what people actually want to
hear about so roughly we're gonna spend
a little time just looking at sort of
what what the industry is looking like
from your networks like what
applications are they out there why are
they interesting why should people care
about them and then have a simple
introduction what on your networks so
we're going to assume that people here
have not necessarily heard about your
networks so this might be a bit boring
for people that have fused tensorflow
and whatnot and then we're going to show
a full example of training a handwriting
classifier classifier and that will show
off all the different pieces that you've
learned and this ready is yeah it'll be
the foundation of all the different
pieces that you need to understand
properly in order to do your own sort of
work in your networks and the principles
are very simple so we're going to flesh
this out a bit and take this a bit
slowly and then the final thing is that
Ali's gonna present the future of the
orphan language your network framework
so kind of what where that where we're
going basically which is pro you of
interest as well for people that use
other frameworks okay cool and then
there'll be lots of question time and we
can focus on something else so some of
the things that were mentioned in the
beginning we might not actually cover I
decided that it would be better to focus
on just the simple things first so that
for the next talks everyone is fully
yeah on the same uh none bored with
what's happening okay and the next talks
are gonna be things like you know audio
processing with neural networks and
image processing etc etc so those will
specialize and focus a lot more on
specific application domains and go in a
lot more detail for how to deal with
those those sorts of domains okay so
there's a prelude to this whole thing so
deep learning in neural networks it's a
at least neural networks are an idea
that go back to the 60s about lots of
the main ideas were let's develop in the
60s and 70s things like back propagation
for training the networks but they've
sort of they fell out of fashion for a
long time and it was really in 2012 when
they came back with a vengeance so what
exactly happened so here's a very simple
problem for humans but for programmers
it's a very high problem so the problem
is the following you have a set of
images so things like you know different
breeds of cats - different animals you
know kettles and pots and all kinds of
things and you have 1.5 million training
images there's like a thousand
categories of these things and the
problem is to take unseen images ones
that you've you know true you've given
the training images you have some you
create some classifier or something that
you want to do and then you get to test
that out on some unseen images and the
question is how good is your can you can
you make a a classifier to do that so it
turns out to be an incredibly hard
problem and this is very famous dataset
called Internet which is exactly this so
there's a thousand categories there's
one point five million training images
see and then the image net organises
they have some unseen test images that
the competitors to this competition that
happens once a year they never get to
see let us get to submit the algorithm
and then it gets automatically graded
son listen competition ran for a number
of years from like 2010 and the sort of
sort of approaches that people used
there was all kinds of approaches and
we'll look at some of them now
but basically this is the sort of error
rate that people were getting so even
the best methods were getting always
above 25% so even 2011 the best method
was roughly about 25% and in 2012 there
was a group led by Geoffrey Hinton from
and exclusive ski that basically were
the first group to use neural networks
on this competition and they had
something like a 15 layer Network and
this thing they use GPUs to Train so
it's a massive dataset and previously
neural networks were just too slow to
train on something as big as this
especially ones with lots of layers so
they were able to Train this massive net
and this was their result they had
something like 17 or 15 percent error
rate and the entire rest of the field
are these little dots over here so they
had suddenly completely difference and
you can see how clustered the top
results all here so the previous methods
you know there were variations on a
theme but really this method was
completely different and it destroyed
the rest the competition and what's
happened since then is that every year
he's method was these neural networks
have gotten better and better so
basically almost all competitors started
using neural networks in the in these
years over here so yeah by the by 2017
the error rate was less than 5% on this
data set okay so this was basically the
catalyst as soon as you have a massive
competition like this where you can't
really cheat because the organizers have
the unseen data then the entire research
community has to basically pay massive
attention to this and that's what they
did
so immediately after
well okay so the other than the sort of
none deep learning approaches with
things like careful feature engineering
so you basically want to find some sort
of feature of the image that you can
feed to things like support vector
machines and yeah these are things that
basically maxed out at like twenty five
percent error rate while steep learning
approach it uses the pixels directly the
zero feature engineering so it basically
it frees the researchers to look for
better networks that are generally good
but they don't have to spend all their
time trying to find better features and
these are very complicated things that
require massive engineering effort but
also it lets the entire system is able
to learn into bands like in this case
the features that you're getting you
know they're sort of there's other
principles involved and sort of deciding
on what what a good feature might be
they're not learnt together with the
actual problem that you're trying to
learn they're just general descriptors
that you try and construct so the neural
network approach was revolutionary in
that as well
in that it it freed people from having
to do this the sort of engineering and
basically every piece of the problem
gets to be optimized in the optimization
procedure which is one of the reasons
why you get amazing performance so many
of these models trend image net can
actually be seen there's a we have a
unreleased neural network repository
which I encourage people to look at it
will be released quite soon but you can
basically get access to these some of
these models for example like this was
one of the I think winning models from
2016 maybe and this thing can be easily
evaluated and correctly predicted as a
peacock and and well from language we
have things like image identifiers that
I've basically built on the same
technology and you can also obviously in
Mathematica you can click and see
exactly what's inside this network and
then delve deeper as well into each of
these layers okay so this is
this was the sort of main catalyst event
that that caused a Cambrian explosion of
different networks and different tasks
that these networks were suddenly put to
useful so it seems there most people in
the field think that this was sort of
the cat the catalytic event and as you
can see for example from Google Trends
basically in 2012 it was a flatline it
was not much happening if you used the
term deep learning for example and then
after 2012 it went up dramatically and
it keeps going up so the other thing
that happened was that people realized
that these neural Nets they weren't just
good at calcifying dogs and cats and
whatnot they were good at all kinds of
domains of of learning tasks from
language translation to speech
recognition etc so I'm just gonna have a
look at a few of these quickly because
it's interesting to know roughly you
know what what can these things do just
to have an idea of yeah of where this
field is currently at and I don't want
people to have to leave with the idea
that all that these networks can do is
something like classify images that's
absolutely not the case they are used in
a wide variety of things so for example
Google Translate they switched to using
neural Nets in 2016 there had a
different kind of system before that and
it had major performance improvements so
from a New York Times article as dawn
broke over Tokyo Google Translate was
the number one trend on Japanese Twitter
just above some cult anime series and a
longer way to the new single from a goal
Idol supergroup everyone wondered how
had Google Translate become sure and can
the artful and you can actually use this
in Mathematica as well by just using
text translation and this calls the
Google neural translation API just
running oops
this one's working okay there go okay
sir
other things what's on most vehicles so
one of the hottest sort of things at
moment is self-driving cars and the sort
of massive rush for the different
companies like we burnt way mow and
whatnot to construct the first
commercially available autonomous
vehicle and one of the key components of
these vehicles is on your networks so
the neural networks do all kinds of
image processing so we actually have one
of them in the neural network repository
and click on this link I didn't actually
put the code in here because it requires
a bit of extra pre-processing code that
is a bit ugly but you can look at this
this link to actually see the full thing
but basically then run it in Mathematica
sorry but the basic idea is that example
we can take a scene and the neural
network can tell you okay these pixels
here correspond to people so it sees
that there are people walking around
exactly where they are where their legs
are at cetera et cetera and it can
obviously say you know there's other
pieces here that are the roads the sky
is up here there's some buildings etc
etc so basically neuro networks are used
to get an idea of the world around the
car other things so things like speech
recognition so basically all the modern
speech recognition systems that you
might find a new phone or anywhere else
will use keep learning now so we
actually have an example of that in the
repository which again you can click on
which is a very good speech recognition
system trained by Baidu on but 8,000
hours of English to other things like
question answering so we have a new
function and 11.3 codes find texture
answer and this was trained with with
the war from your network framework and
there's a nice blog post that you guys
can look at from jerome from our group
about exactly how that was done so yeah
I mean here's a simple example we can
give it a question and there's some big
paragraph of
and the question is see this works so
this thing if you use this yourself
it'll be downloading the network that
actually does does all of the stuff what
happened there
okay there go so correctly extracted
that it's one meter the size of the dodo
from this text and basically for this
sort of task every every method is a
neural network method so it's basically
the only game in town for this sort of
thing okay so rapidly on to other things
like reinforcement learning so I'll
forego people might have heard of this
so go was a game that was generally
considered an almost unsolvable game and
at least a decade away for having any
sort of reasonable solution and deep my
instructs the community by releasing a
go player that meets one of the previous
world champions nice at all
and there's also yeah quickly after that
there's a a new version of the school
for go zero which completely learns from
scratch and it's a lot better than even
I'll forego so this year one of the key
components was was in your net so other
random things so things that you might
not even think are really learning tasks
so things like restyling images so I
might say I went to his a Content image
I want to restyle that into the style of
this thing for example so I can run this
and here's the resulting image and you
can do this with you know all kinds of
different images and this is the
foundation of imagery style which is so
and nourish function in Mathematica so
one of the trends that I want you to see
is that for internal functionality we
are using our own framework to do all
these things like imagery style and the
question answering to all kinds of other
things that are coming up from speech
recognition - yeah translation
so this framework is it has to be
powerful enough for us to actually train
these things ourselves and so users
basically get yeah they get a very good
framework okay another random example is
let's say colorization so in this case
you want to say has a black and white
image
please colorize that reconstruct what a
plausible color scheme looks like for
that so we can try this and there's the
new image so the network of us has to
recognize you know this is grass this is
probably a dog and dogs come in certain
colors when they look like this etc etc
okay so it could go on and on there's a
lot of things that these things can do
from reconstructing 3d faces from 2d
faces to geo-locating an image based on
yeah just the image and a massive
training set that they were trained on -
all kinds of other things like medical
imaging even I think today was well
yesterday was the FDA oh I think 58 one
of the what is the medical organization
in the u.s. they approved a diabetic
retinopathy detector that's based on
deep learning for medical use so medical
imaging is a massive massive field
there's all kinds of NLP stuff natural
language processing from sentiment
analysis to all kinds of other things so
you could already go to this the sites
and you can find a bunch of other thing
of networks that are currently run a
Belen in Mathematica ok so now that
we've we've seen and hopefully motivated
somewhat why people should be interested
in the sort of thing that they can be
applied to all these different problem
domains that previously didn't have
really good solutions so what are neural
networks so let's spend a bit of time
thinking about about this question so
the modern term for neural network is
actually differentiable programming and
we'll see why that is quite soon and
also
that people know there's a very nice
introduction to neural Nets tutorial in
the Mathematica documentation there's a
link for that there and some of it is
based on that okay so the very most
basic building block of a neural network
is a layer so in other frameworks might
call this an operator so at layer an
operator it's some basic piece of
computation that acts on numeric tensors
so let's have a very simple example here
so this limit called element wise layer
which allows you to have layers for for
all sorts of yeah element wise functions
like 10h and clip and all kinds of
things of that sort so one thing is sort
of property of these things is that they
can only act on numeric tensors so
here's an example so element wise layer
we can apply this to some input and this
is the same as in top-level if we said
yeah and they're both the same result so
here's where the differential
programming idea comes in so the idea is
that you want to have layers that are
differentiable and the reason for that
is going to be for being able to
optimize and learn what the parameters
are in these networks
efficiently so the idea is that if every
piece is differentiable and if you stick
them all together it will remain
differentiable and will be very
efficient to optimize so this way of
differentiating these layers with
network gradient so you can say give it
some data and you say I want to get the
gradient of the port input and what is a
port well
these layers if you click on it you can
expand it it says there's a number of
ports so there's an input port and
output port and the reason for this is
that you want some way of specifying
able to specify unambiguously you know
if you want to connect up let's say the
output of this thing to something else
in this case it's trivial there's just
one input output but for many layers
they can have multiple inputs or
multiple outputs
so you can specify in this case
explicitly like I want the gradient for
the input port so we can do that and
that's exactly equivalent to just
differentiating symbolically and then in
this case just replacing that's symbolic
variable with what some inputs and what
yeah what this is really yeah
okay so there's another that properties
of these layers have so one difference
between these layers and other
mathematical functions is that they can
operate transparently on GPUs so it's
become imperative to train on GPUs like
CPUs it is too slow so this can be
either CPU or GPU for example you can
also if you have multiple GPUs you can
specify potentially which GPU wanna run
this thing on like if this if I had four
GPUs then I could do something like that
three GPUs okay so everything works on
GPU so any combination of these things
will also work on GPU then some other
random things so one is a there's
something and decide you have shape
inference so these layers they if you
tell it what the input size is going to
be so I'm telling it that in this case
it's a matrix of 4 rows and 3 2 columns
then it will automatically infer what
the output shape is gonna be and we'll
see a bit later why this is important
and useful ok so one of them the most
important differences though between
just normal functions and Mathematica
and and layers is that layers can have
learn about parameters so if this was
all that I was doing so like just it has
another version of 10h or whatever like
there's no way that this thing can learn
anything because you just you know it's
just a function that you're constructing
explicitly but the magic happens when
you have learn more parameters so layers
that have learner more parameters
there's they will often look like this
there'll be something and initialized
and you click on it there's the ports
the input in the output
and again they've got if I told it what
the input was and I tell it that this
thing has you know it's a three layer
net OS area with three neurons the same
they don't knows exactly what the output
is gonna be but it also has these these
parameters here weights and biases so
these are things that you want to learn
and they can adapt based on the data so
in the beginning they don't have any
values right they're just they're not
defined and if you try to extract the
values then it'll just say automatic but
there's a function called net initialize
which allows you to initialize these
weights and biases to some random values
and that's the general philosophy with
no net works is that you before training
you need to any set yeah you need to
randomly initialize them to something
that's not zero
like the weights if everything is zero
then it has huge difficulties learning
and there's actually there's a very
complicated procedure for deciding on
what the scale of the random data should
be that you're initializing these things
to and all of this sort of thing our
framework completely automates so
there's no decisions you need to make
okay and then now you can you can say
net extract and I want to have a stock
layer here I've initialized it so if I
look at the weights is actually awesome
weights now and I could do the same of
biases okay and obviously what that goes
without saying that I could I could now
evaluate this thing as well so if not
see so if I was to say dot two of let's
say one this thing takes a vector of
size two it'll now evaluate but dot one
if I try to evaluate this thing on that
it'll say cannot evaluate nets because I
haven't specified the value for with
weights okay so all of these examples so
far are things with one input port so
one classic example of something that
has multiple input ports is a loss
function so a loss function is something
very simple it basically takes in inputs
and a targets then it tries to make it
recipe have a high number so it's always
one number
a loss function and there tries to have
a very low number if they if the if the
target and the input are very similar
and it has a very high number if they're
very far apart in this case it's it's
basically the Euclidean distance between
two vectors for example if these were
vectors that I would be putting in so
here's a very simple example so I have
an input and target they're quite
different if I make the target II you
know this is 4 and this is 1 if I make
this 99 this number goes up but if I
made this 1 this number is now smaller
so this number gives the network an idea
of how close it is to the truth and this
is the key part that is used for
training the network
oh sorry ok is it ok make it wider ah
that's not getting ok it's like better
ok I think that's wider cool
sorry about that okay so there's also a
way you can list what what layers
actually available to you in the system
and each of these obviously has a lot of
documentation and they all have
different so for behavior so some of
them are just you know very similar to
what Mathematica would do so things like
a pen layer it does basically the same
thing as a pinned or like dr+ or dot
layer it does the same thing as
Mathematica dots but then there's a
whole bunch of layers that have no
analogs in top level Mathematica
so things like instance normalization
layer which does some sort of
normalization of the data or spatial
transformation layer and whatnot
ok and this is a like becoming
proficient in using your networks
involves understanding what all these
different layers do and when they
appropriate to use and that's gonna be a
probably larger topic that will be
carried on for the next sessions
okay so these are one of them what is
what is the linear layer do at least so
this is the simplest learning at learner
belayer and this is sort of one of the
oldest layer types and I'm a mess
mention that these layers they keep
growing one of the reasons is that
people invent new layers all the time
and as they invent them we want to
implement them and have them in our
framework okay so the simplest loanable
way is just a linear layer so the
mathematic equivalent of that will be
this you just dot part I think
producting in the weights and the data
and then you're adding some bias term so
the data is some sort of a vector and
the weight is a matrix so basically what
this layer is doing and we can just
verify that it is actually the same you
know we can extract the actual weights
oh dear what's going on there I didn't
say initialize that there you go okay so
although this is doing and I feel linear
layer it's often called a fully
connected layer because you could
interpret you know there's a let's say
an input vector of length three so one
two three so this is what you know this
input here might look like and there's
basically the matrix can be that you've
got the weight matrix can be interpreted
as sort of new connections between this
neuron and you know the neurons of the
output and there's a weight per
connection so that weight matrix
basically represents that and all that
it is is a linear transformation of the
data and linear transformations you know
they can have things like they can
rotate the vector they can rescale it
they can shift to the bit etc etc so
whatever linear transformation can do
this this layer can learn to do that
thing if it's good for producing the
predicted results okay but this is a big
topic and things like what a convolution
layers do and what - you know pruning
layers do etc etc conv
we're currently as these are going to be
topics that will be very deeply explored
I think in the next talks so I'm not
going to go into that too much
okay so layers I think we've understood
not right so layers they act on numeric
tenses and they have a whole bunch of
properties like the differentiable and
they work on all different devices etc
etc but layers themselves are not very
useful like just that linear layer it
can't really learn much and in fact one
linear layer is the same as logistic
regression if you were to do a
classification problem and try and solve
it with a single hidden layer Network or
linear regression as if you try and you
know if you're predicting a numerical
value with a single linear layer so and
those are very weak sort of learning
systems so one of the main ideas of
neural networks or deep learning against
is that you want to have a long set of
transformations a deep set of
transformations that allow much more
complicated behavior to be learnt than
just single layers so first container
type is a chain so this is very simple
so a chain is simply linear
sorry yeah it's a sequence of operations
so a linear sequence so it has one input
we can try this out so if we look at
this thing here so this thing has one
input it has one output and it just is
doing first the 10h and then it's doing
there's a sigmoid on the data and this
is exactly the same as this example and
top level and you can also verify that
they the same okay this is a bit of a
silly example because you could in this
case it would also be equipment so
element wise layer is very powerful
there it can have for example something
like this so it just exceed my edge
takes and that's and that takes in and
that's a perfectly valid layer you can
compose all the different primitives
that element-wise lahic has and you can
make a pure function and that's a
perfectly valid element wise layer so
this is this would be the better way of
writing this thing but this is just a
show that what what's F does okay so a
lot of networks and traditionally almost
all the networks have been just chains
so yeah the sort of traditional image
classification networks even the one
that one image net they can all be
represented by it by this chain
construct that's that's all they need
however what happened after the 2012
image net results was that people will
realize that there's a lot of power and
having actual or more complicated sort
of structures that you can have and one
of them is the graph so a very simple
graph would be something like this you
have two different inputs and these
inputs the first input goes into @nh the
second one goes into logistic sigmoid
and then they get added up together and
then returned so this graph that is that
you can the first sort of list here and
this can be a list or an association so
if it's a list
it means you basically yeah you have all
the layers that you want and then the
second argument phonograph is a list
that gives the connectivity structure so
just exactly like graph or graph works
so in this case I'm saying with the
first port if the inputs is going to the
first layer so 10h and the second part
of the input goes to the second element
in here this one here and then both of
these go to the total layer which totals
them up and you can do the same thing
with Association and then with names
rather some people find that much easier
so at an age goes to that and then you
have this stuff here for some pool
changing to being 10 H I person prefer
that that method as well and this must
all sleep in association and these ones
must be changed to do
okay so the question then is yeah is
this equipment what is this equipment -
and in this case yeah it's just function
composition like this okay so you can
build very complicated structures with
neck Raph you can also differentiate it
because all the layers are
differentiable so will the net graph be
differentiable and this is an important
point is that containers behave exactly
like just normal layers so they're
differentiable there on the GPUs but
they can also be nested so in a chain
expects a layer over here but a neck
chain is a layer as well so this is
perfectly valid syntax and if you dig
deep into this thing you know you can
you can find the different layers of
neck graph of net chain sorry okay and
obviously the models in the repository
almost all some form of container so an
example of this would be this restyle
restyling net this thing has two
different inputs the style image and the
content image and it does some
processing and you can dig deeper and
click on these things and get yeah see
what the world looks like
okay so containers are important for
building more complicated structures but
containers layers they still only ever
operate on numerical tensors but what we
had what you might have noticed right
the beginning was acting on actual
images like we would take an F model
this thing and it would apply directly
to the image so how does that yeah how
do we how does it happen so the basic
idea is that we have another construct
and this construct is quite different
from anything that we've seen in other
frameworks so the construct is the idea
of an S encoder so net encode is our
special
almost like a lair but they can't go
inside the net graph for nets a chain or
they can't they're not they're not real
they're they're not differentiable they
don't work on all the devices etc etc
but they can be attached to the inputs
of other layers which we'll see now so
basically what they do is they take some
some some types or like an image or an
audio object or text or any other other
types that you might want to operate on
within your networks and it basically
produces the appropriate tensor from
that thing and you can see from this so
this says okay this must be a grayscale
image it has one color channel there's
no amino variance images that you could
set as well and it's got an output shape
of this so if you give it an image it
produces the stencil so it makes a
guarantee that the tense of the
listening outputs is 1 by 12 by 12
tensor now if this image was much bigger
it would just reshape it if it was a
different kind of space it would conform
it so it can basically guarantee to the
network this is the kind of 10 so that
you'll be getting and another cool thing
that you can do is this sort of thing
with with the encoder is that it can
operate directly on files as well so if
I have a file for some image then it's
can directly run this and give you a
tensor and there should be one by 12 by
12 up see sway 1 by 12 by 12 great and
the reason where this is powerful is
that you can do out of coal burning for
images and audio files with this because
you just have to you can use the file as
the natural data point to feed to the to
the training for example so you don't
actually have to load all the files into
the into memory you can just have them
on disk and then have just give the file
names and then net train can act
directly on them all the networks can
act directly on just the file paths so
file powers are completely valid inputs
to these encoders
and if you're more interested in I was
gonna touch more on this later but I
decide to simplify things so if you are
interested in training on large data
sets then there's a tutorial on doing
this okay which I recommend you looking
and so there's a whole bunch of I think
coders from audio - characters - for
tokens - yeah you can write your own
custom encoder as well so it depends on
what what data type that you were
dealing with okay and as I mentioned the
main sort of property of these things is
that remember the input port so you can
specify what the sizes for the input
port but instead of doing that you can
attach and encode it to it and if I do
that instead of saying what the size is
it will tell you that the input is an
image in this case and what this means
is that you can act directly so this is
this case the pruning layer you can act
directly on an image if you try to do
that without this it will just complain
because it's not a type that it accepts
so if we did this putting layer and we
said let's give it some image data
supplied to port input was not a row
tensor of rank greater than one okay and
one more thing if you remember the the
networks that we showed right in the
beginning for image net these things had
the magical property that's here's then
a chain they could be directly applied
to the image just give it to the yep
give the image to network and the reason
for that is that it has this image in
code on top and you can always extract
the image encoder you can say net
extracts of the inputs and you can see
what the this image encode is doing is
resizing them to 299 by 299 it has some
mean images so I mean image it has and
that's RGB color space so that's why
this network just works out of the box
so if other frameworks you often have
extra pre-processing code that would
have to conform the image into the
certain to the size that the network
requires
okay
the basic almost-brother of the analog
of the net and coda is for the input is
that there's gonna be a net ACOTA for
the output the reason for this is very
simple it's not a lot of networks for
example like classification tasks you
really want
yeah the network is always gonna give
you back a numeric tensor but that's not
really what you want you want some sort
of class you want to say is this a dog
or a cat for example so what this does
is that if you create this decoder you
say it's a class decoder and there's
yeah it's two classes there's dog and
cats if I give it a probability vector
it will then interpret it'll take for
the maximum probability which is 0.9 and
say this was a cat because that's the
one that cross wants two or nine and you
can use this exactly like a classifier
function which is that's you can ask for
different properties here like what are
the probabilities don't give you an
association or the probabilities for
each of the things and exactly the same
analog if you have us you can attach
this to the output port of of network
and this is you can see now add these
ports or some names like you have you
need ways of referring to them so like
if this if they were multiple outputs
for something how do i specify which
output to attach some Dakota to for
example okay in this case there's a
softmax layer which basically just
produces it takes a random vector and it
produces a normalized vector so there's
sums to 1 if we apply this now softmax
directly works on or put it directly
produces something like this which is
definitely not just a numeric array okay
so the same thing happens with with
these networks so things like this
internet network it has a whole bunch of
classes and you click on this thing
you'll see that the output has a class
attached to it which we could extract
and if we run this Network it means
instead of giving you you know just a
big splurge of probabilities like
there's a vector of size a thousand one
in this case you can actually get the
real class from that when you can
obviously if you want the probabilities
you can ask for them here as well but
this might take some time okay and you
can get the outputs Dakota in this case
and you can get the class labels and all
that sort of thing out if you already
want okay so I'm hope that people can
see sort of what the motivation of this
thing is that it makes it makes the
networks very clean like this is ready
to go this network
it doesn't require lots of
post-processing scripts and whatnot so
okay so now that we've discussed the
main sort of concepts so those decoders
encoders containers and layers so now we
would actually want to train something
so that these networks are not very
interesting unless you can actually do
some you know that can do some learning
so how do we do this well there's a
whole bunch of automation that's that's
introduced by the framework but we I'm
going to show you some examples where I
don't make use of this automation and
just do it very explicitly that you can
see exactly what's going on so here's a
very simple example we have some data
which is pretty much a straight line 1
goes to 2 goes to 4 3 goes to 6 for
state and here's a very simple net that
we want to have to solve this problem so
in this case we're predicting one number
a vector of size 1 and here's where the
magic happens so we have an input it
comes in it goes through the linear
layer and this has parameters and we
want to find the parameters so that the
prediction of this linear layer is the
same as the target prediction so that
means mean squared last layer becomes
very small
so if we do it right now we've
initialized this network let's just
random initialization this is pretty big
so obviously that's what we expect
because you know these these parameters
haven't seen any of the data that is
randomly picked so currently the
predictions of the network of this
linear layer don't match at all what the
target looks like okay so now we can
actually train it and there's a very
simple construct called net rain so net
training takes a network that takes some
data the training data and it will train
so that happened very quickly we can do
it again so basically this tells you
here what that the lasts what the output
looks like as a function of training
iterations so it does many iterations
and you hope that that thing goes down
because you want you want to loss you
know to get smaller which means that
your predictions and your target match
and now we can check that exactly the
same thing which previously we had 15.3
one if we run this now as a trained
network we get something like that so
this network now has learnt to predict
what the target looks like okay and we
can also extract the parameters we had a
net with some weights and we have a new
network the Train Network and we can see
what the weights looked like so for the
Train nets the way its are completely
different and that's the whole point of
training but it can change the
parameters okay and just a quick rough
idea of how this works it uses something
called gradient descent and this is
where the differentiability comes in and
where it's so important so the basic
idea is suppose this was that this J
here is the loss so it's a function of
the weights of the network right over
the parameters of network so we want to
find yeah so for different parameters
that you have these this loss is gonna
be different values and as we saw
so there's gonna be a point though where
there's gonna be a minimum and in fact
there's multiple minimums
so there's a whole landscape of minima
but the basic idea is that if you have
if you're a blob and you know if you're
sitting over here and in parameter space
so if you're yeah you're parameter puts
you on over here then if you have the
gradient the gradient gives you an idea
of the direction that you must go so
that you get more closer to the minimum
and that's what net rain basically does
so it uses the differentiability of the
nets and it moves you in the direction
where you need to go okay so that's also
very similar you might people might
realize two things like an minimize or
find minima except that it's it's vastly
more efficient for various reasons okay
so that's that's the basic idea of the
training and you don't have to worry - I
mean yeah it's good to know what it's
doing but net train does automate a lot
of that that's stuff for you so now that
we have this this background let us
actually look at a real sort of example
and this is often considered a toy
example but it is the simplest way oh
yeah maybe the least trivial tour
example that you can have that actually
does something nice so we get the data
and we can look at some examples and
probably most of you have seen this sort
of thing and one of the reasons for
using this example as a starting point
is that a lot of people have seen it and
it's familiar the problem that is
involved for this so the problem is very
simple you have some handwritten digits
and you have the actual label and so you
want to predict for unseen images you
want to have Makia you want to learn how
to predict the correct label for those
so what have you learnt well the first
thing obviously and this is something
that's I think the next speakers will
emphasize a lot but basically it's very
seldom where you will be actually
putting together very complicated
nets from scratch with lots and lots of
layers so the most common thing is you
know the community the neural network
community has spent a lot of money and
time looking for good architectures for
doing certain problems so your first
instinct should always be to say let's
go to the neural network repository and
find something that does something
similar to what we're doing it's image
classification there's a whole bunch of
incredible networks that have one on
image net that'll be a very good fit for
what you're doing and it's unlikely that
you'll ever find a better architecture
so this should be your first instinct
almost always find an existing network
for a certain task and one other things
so one of the reason why it's very nice
to use their the repository is that you
guarantee that the implementation was
correct it's very easy to see a paper
and then make mistakes with these
numbers like this is a very small net
you prove not gonna make mistakes but
for some of the networks that have five
hundred or a thousand layers it's very
easy to make small mistakes and then the
whole network doesn't work properly
so yeah so this should be a first end
instinct and in fact for this particular
task is a very famous network that we
have called net which at some point
supposedly sorted about ten percent of
America's checks this was like in the
early 90s young McCune worked for I
think Bell Labs and they made one of the
first sort of industrial-grade neural
network recognition machines for check
digit recognition so it has a very
pristine history or prestigious history
so this this network does exactly we
want it's very simple Network it has
convolution layers and pulling and this
is something that for the image talk I'm
pretty sure they'll explain carefully
what these layers do and why they're
special and why they used for images but
yeah so you could run this model
immediately and you'll see that it works
but let's do this from scratch so using
all the different things we learnt and I
also want to say if you want to see the
most efficient way of the fastest way of
doing this er tasks there's a tutorial
and
classification and it's very very short
it's a very very simple few lines of
code to actually do this the simplest
way but the simplest way is not the most
general way so the simplest way works
problems where there's basically one
prediction where there's one input but
it doesn't work for anything else so
we're gonna show for this basically the
general approach that will work for any
sort of problem even though it makes for
this very very simple problem that makes
it look a lot harder than it is
okay so the first thing that we want is
we want a decoder because we want this
thing to predict the classes and that
the classes are going to be between 0 9
the digits are between that and we also
wants an encoder which takes an image
and it makes sure that it's 28 by 28 the
size and they're going to be grayscale
ok so the next thing is to actually
define this convolutional network so I'm
not going to explain all that carefully
about what the motivation is for each of
these things maybe the only thing I'll
say I mentioned is that convolutions are
usually used for structures like sounds
like spectrograms or or images which are
large and you don't want blowup of your
parameters like the fully connected
layer or the linear layer gets
incredibly large for images like if you
have a 500 by 500 image and then you
need a matrix that multiplies that you
have a massive you just have a blow-up
of parameters there's a whole bunch of
other reasons like there's certain
symmetries that are encoded or in
variances that you that your hard code
into this here so you say things like
for a classification problem I don't
care that you know the object could be
anywhere in the image I don't really
care
and that's invariance to just shifting
the object in the image that's one of
the reasons why you have a putting layer
for example so you can prove that a
proving layer makes it equal variance to
translation
sword objects - translations in image
and so this is sort of principle and
neural networks is that if you can
encode structures if you know that
there's some structure and your input
you want to use layers appropriate for
that to exploit that structure and it
makes learning a lot more efficient but
this is yeah this is a longer topic
that's maybe we can do it some other
time on the next version or maybe even
the questions okay but basically yeah so
this is a whole bunch of convolution is
there's an under ERT call like a ramp
layer and this is a very important thing
for you to know as well so if you
plotted this thing it'll just look like
let's say - 3 - 3 and this thing is it's
flat and then it goes I put like this
this is also called regulator sometimes
or rectified linear layer and you'll see
them between things like linear layers
or convolutions whatever and they
basically break the sort of linearity
each of these these operations is the
linear operation and so you have a bit
of nonlinear behavior here and that
helps the network learn much better ok
so we've now created this thing now this
is where where things become more
complicated than they need to be for
this very simple example but I'm going
to show how to do this for the general
case so here I'm actually constructing
the training net so for these simple
examples you can actually feed this
straight Internet train and it will
it'll construct that the whole learning
graph of the training Nets itself and
then give you back the original network
that you had but that doesn't work for
networks especially when there's yeah
when there's multiple inputs or outputs
so what you can do is in this case yeah
I his linette's we're just having that
initialize nest so the input goes to
that and then the input goes the Loess
which we've just explicitly added here
and this will be cross entropy lost
layer and cross entropy losses are
usually what you use for classification
so this is one of the things that you
have learn as well like what what losses
are appropriate for different tasks and
this is a very good loss if you have two
different probability distributions that
you're comparing okay and we can
evaluate this on some training examples
and you'll see that it's quite large
okay so we have this training net and we
want to find the parameters of the net
so that the tire the prediction that it
makes is similar to what the target is
and the lass
gives you a number that will be small
when that's when it happens
there's one more thing which is that
this net now has two ports and as a
target port in an input port so the most
general way of representing data when
there are multiple ports is the
Association form so basically you have
this sort of thing so you have one port
and it has a bunch of examples and
there's another port that has a bunch of
examples so for training this is the
most general form and some networks you
know they might have five of these these
ports and so you have you can easy
represent the data okay now let's train
this thing so this is the more
complicated syntax of the previous thing
that I had but let's let's start this so
one the first thing to note is that I'm
using and when you use GPU now not
everyone can use GPU you can only use it
if you have an Nvidia graphics card
unfortunately so whilst it's running we
can explain what all the different
things are I'm sorry also this display
looks a bit strange for presentations
the Sun bugged
it makes it look small okay so it's busy
training so in a circle lived in pieces
whilst is doing that so the training
nets this is the training data
Association there's a validation set now
this is very important so when you use
things that classify it there's a lot of
things that
automated for you to prevent things like
overfitting so if a fitting means that
you just you do very well in your your
training data but you did terribly on
any other data and there's a very good
tutorial on overfitting if you're really
interested in that called to troll yeah
training neural networks with rigor
ization so basically this validation set
where it does it's not allowed to use
this data for training but it checks as
you can see here this last curve the
blue is the validation performance and
as you can see it's getting better and
better on the training set but it's not
getting better on the validation set so
what this will do is it'll say okay we
can take the the network that did the
best for on the validation set and
return that to the user so for example
this graph might look like you know the
validation set goes down down down and
then suddenly it can go up again and
that's the sort of classic signature of
overfitting so in this case it doesn't
look like it's over fitted too much it
looks quite fine but this thing if you
if you provided a validation set it'll
protect you quite well from any sort of
overfitting because it'll just take the
point that it the best on a validation
set on oh it wasn't overfitting yet and
that's really probably the most
recommended thing for people to do to
save themselves from that problem
because yeah like net trained doesn't
automatically you know deal with fitting
like classify and predict my - okay how
much yes other things like how many
rounds of training this means how many
times does it go through the entire data
set default stops and you can obviously
okay I should run this one more time you
can stop at the training or any points
so if I wanted to stop it now I could
just say stop and return the training
results for me okay that was maybe not
the greatest idea because I have to
retrain it for a little bit at least and
yes and this last or anything was that
there's an argument all here
it just means that it returns this neck
train results object so normally if you
don't give this argument it will return
the actual train network but in this
yeah in this case it gives back the
Train network that's in those objects
but it gives back all the other training
information as well so things like what
was the validation lasts etc etc and
we'll see that now so this is almost
done this will take a lot longer than
your CPU unfortunately okay let's stop
it now okay so we have this network
that's been trains with the result
objects so from the result object
there's a whole bunch of properties that
you have so things like you can get a
nice plot of the you know of the lass
for training from the training set which
is the orange and also the blue which is
the validation set loss and we can see
that it hasn't over fitted too much
because the validation set is talked
going down okay we can also get the
network out so results train net will
give you back the neck graph so what we
really want those we want the the
prediction Network so we want to get
outs you know the snake Raph but also
inside the neck graph there's of nodes
Lynette which is the prediction graph we
can discard the rest of the network
because we're not doing training anymore
so there's a little bit of annoyance
that you have to do which is that think
odors disappear if you you know this
thing is now yeah yeah if you extract
this thing you know the output and code
is not there and then input and code is
not there is you have to just put them
back which is pretty simple it's a
natural place part and we can now use
this train that to actually make some
predictions so this is a tomb now we can
get some probabilities out it's pretty
confident that this is a three but it's
a bit unsure as you can see like it's
been cut out of this so that's pretty
good that it's 100 some confidence and
you can do things like attend the
accuracy of this thing
which gets about 98.6 so that's roughly
yeah so for classification tiles it's
very simple to get metrics art because
you can just use classify measurements
so it's the classification tasks with
classify measurements and the same thing
that happens with predictor if you're
doing regression okay and oh this was
this is a duplicates up see you can do
the same thing with classify as well so
you can try a run classify him and you
can see how much simpler classify tis
than this so classifies fully automated
it does all the pre-processing it as if
yeah it does everything for you
basically and all this rigmarole that we
went through you can achieve something
similar classifying except that
classifier has a lot of limitations it's
not as flexible you can't do out of
court learning etc etc and obviously if
the only problem was to do simple image
classification then something I classify
might be appropriate okay this is stuff
it's not that much time okay
well we didn't have train very long
we've got that okay so just a summarize
quickly so I've given a very basic
introduction to to the framework and
different pieces of it and there's
obviously I gave lots of links to things
that are more complicated so things like
article training yeah there's all kinds
of other ways of dealing with
overfitting so things like he's in crop
out or other kinds of rigor ization so
those are things that you probably have
to look at yourself okay and the last
thing I wanna leave you with before I
give you to tally is that just quick
sort of rundown of this framework so
first of all let's say it's an
industrial-strength scalable framework
we use all the latest Nvidia libraries
we use em X node as a back-end and we
contribute to MX n as well so all that
yeah all the difference all the
companies that are working on MX node
and it's backed by a whole bunch of
companies
from Amazon to Apple to others users
automatically gets all the benefits that
accrue to ya to all the things that
improvements are made to em X naught we
also use this extensively N and Wolfram
research for we're developing a whole
bunch of functionality based on your
networks from speech recognition to
things you've already seen like the
question answering to image identify
this image contents is coming so there's
something like a list of 70 different
functions that we've got that we want to
make with this framework so it's not
just something that's yes but we don't
use we use it very extensively and yeah
we're also plan to have the best
repository of networks which is already
I think a lot better than any other
frameworks repository so we're putting a
lot of effort into collecting from nets
from other frameworks so we convert them
for you we convert the pre-processing
into Mathematica occurs if there's
pre-processing involved and all the
hassle of yeah of converting and
converting is a tricky business it might
it's unfortunately a lot harder than it
needs to be right now so yes we and also
the networks that we train ourselves are
going to go onto this repository so
those hopefully 70 functions that are on
our lists those Nets will be available
to to users so one thing I think I'm
here they've been comments about this as
well there's no locking so we thought it
was a very important principle to follow
that users of the framework are not
forced to have their stuff only in
Mathematica because you might want to
you know yeah deploy on tensorflow
surveying or who knows what like there's
a lot of options you might have and we
definitely want to lock you in so we can
we already support import/export 2mx not
I should have actually put a link for
that but yeah and there's you can look
in the documentation for that and we
also have plans to supports
sort of the main candidate for a
completely cross-platform format which
was started by the PI torch and cafe 2
and Microsoft CNT K framework people but
it's now been adopted by MX nuts and
China and a bunch of others and we
hopefully will support that as well to
both import and export to that and yeah
and we've hopefully we've tried to make
ourselves be easier to use than other
frameworks and this is sort of the
selling point I guess that we want to
have is that we want to be as simple to
use as possible and for certain things
you might see for the next talks so
things like true variable length
sequence support these are things that
are very hard to do in other frameworks
that Kerris and whatnot well you have to
do an masking and icky things and things
like think coders and whatnot it just
makes it very simple because everything
which runs there's no extra Python
packages that you need to run to process
your audio images everything is just
part of the language so yeah and yeah
and the single so it works out of the
box on all different platforms from
raspberry pi where it ships with - yeah
all the other major platforms and also I
think I didn't mention was that we do
support quite simple cloud deployment so
like API function and cloud apply that
allow you to deploy these networks onto
dwarfing cloud for you to make api's
with all right cool I think that's
basically at the end of my my talk and
tell you we'll be with you next so
thanks a lot so how do I stop
you
sorry those meters I forgot to mention
that there's one last poll and this poll
is basically what's yeah what users
would want to see the most in the next
version of America for the new record
framework Thanks
you
right so this is tele so with Sebastian
as he mentioned I'm one of the
developers of the deep learning
framework of Mathematica and I'll I'll
quickly summarize this poll and then we
will look at my section of the talk
which is kind of some of the future work
that we're planning and and some of the
features that you can expect to see in
future versions of Mathematica one quick
question of my mind sharing my screen
it's hard to tell now yet telly I'm
gonna hide the poll results and then I
will hand over access to you thank you
cool looks like people are pretty keen
on seeing a book which is very
interesting it's certainly something it
would be fun to write okay great can
everyone see my notebook yes we can
great cool so I want to cover forth
before is it done at much time I've got
about ten minutes that's when a cover
for is and then maybe leave open to
questions the foyer is we're
concentrating on you could kind of you
can kind of group things up into things
about scalability so that means making
sure framework can work on so bigger and
bigger problems on training and more
devices being friendlier to long term
training that lasts many hours or days
then there's economics which is making
it easier to use in to define networks
clearly to sort of see what's going on
then there's there's flexibility and
that's making sure that we can actually
represent some of the latest networks
that can sometimes have more exotic kind
of layers in them or sort of funny
things going on that we haven't yet that
we don't we may not have layers defined
or we may not allow you to do the kind
of manipulations that you need to
implement a particular technique that's
making sure we have those things then
the fourth area is interoperability and
that kind of really means making sure
that once you've you've trained a
network in in Mathematica and the
Wolfram language you'll get it out use
it production use it in conjunction with
other tools and and the inverse of that
so like taking networks that other
people have have trained in in other
frameworks whether it's Kerris or pi
torch and getting them into Wolfram
language that you can use of our
features so let me start with
scalability the primary thing that we
were working on and it almost Shipton in
11.3 is most GPU support the rough idea
is that you just got as be able to
specify instead of a particular GPU like
currently you can say GPU one or two
things modern GPUs allow be able to say
GPU all and that will mean that we will
divvy up the batches into smaller
batches that are given to each GPU
independently and then the gradients are
are synchronized using the high
performance and it's easier library
that's
that nvidia provides this will also be
possible for evaluating a net on large
quantities of data and you might want to
do that to measure its its accuracy or
to conduct experiments of another kind
and yeah you'll be able to make use of
one of the GPS that you have on your
system so the next feature it will be
supporting and again this is very low
hanging fruit and related to other
things I'll talk about is support for
1/2 precision and double precision types
of array and and the computation in the
framework and what that means in
practice is for 1/2 precision that you
can train faster and your nets wall will
occupy less memory while training and
also when saved to disk and in some
cases with some hardware there
potentially quite big speed ups so
Nvidia likes to talk about the the the
tensor cause that they have on their v1
hundreds these are available and you can
buy them of course but you can also use
them on cloud compute services like like
AWS they have I mean reading roughly
awful numbers a factor of 10 offer a
factor of 10 kind of increasing in
maximum throughput of floating-point
operations if you just give up after
half the precision of all the numbers
you use it does mean that you you have
to you use various tricks to extra
training as more this is stable enough
to be useful so we will do these things
automatically but the payoff is
potentially quite large for that and
then just because it's it's not that
much extra work to to ensure we've also
make sure that you can you can use
double precision certainly gonna be used
by less people that it will unlock
certain use cases that I think are quite
interesting the way all you the way
you'll use this in practice is by
providing an option called a working
precision either to net train if you
want to train at lower precision or to
just to the net when you when you
evaluating it at all that'll allow you
to train at higher or lower precision
the default of courses
you're 32 okay one other thing that we
this is more speculative of course is to
offer the ability to train with AWS link
and ADA Bleus link is currently in very
useful packages built into Mathematica
it's not it's not documented at the
moment but it may be in the future and
it allows you to kind of interface with
with Amazon's AWS compute service
services I should say and the basic idea
is that you'll be able to use a very
similar kind of interface to what you
would do to do training locally but
you'll be able to point it at data
that's living on a cloud or in history
bucket for example and an instance that
you've that you've spun up and that this
training will then happen it's kind of
independent from your session in the
cloud communicated over a channel we
have this new channel framework that
will unlock that you can sort of observe
a training without having to remain
connected to it in any way that might be
quite a nice sort of usability and
scalability improvement another thing
that's actually quite connected to this
this particular feature would be to
ensure that you can resume training from
where you left off if the training gets
interrupted for whatever reason you can
kind of do this now but the a set amount
of ephemeral state has lost state that
lives in the optimizer so things like
STD and Adam maintain special optimizes
maintain special states and if you stock
them and throw away that if you stopped
net training and and started again that
state has to kind of like resynchronize
it's often and that can change the
results so you want to make it that you
can resume exactly from where you left
off and the place that this would come
particularly in handy with respect to
AWS link is a few using so-called spot
instances which is it's a feature of
Amazon's infrastructure that lets you
rent training rent compute Hardware much
more cheaply than you would if you
but would use that they're kind of more
normal services the downside is that is
that your your instances can be
terminated at any time if the price that
you offering it goes below the market
rate and so if your if that termination
happens you want to make sure that you
can start it again and not have not have
lost all of your progress or does not
affect the results too much so next
moving on to the economics this is the
thing that I I am particularly excited
about net graph which is best and
described in some detail is is great but
I don't think it's a particularly
intuitive way to build computational
graphs it does have some advantages
which is once you've built this graph
it's actually quite quite
straightforward to look at it and see
what it does sort of visually and and
you can of course drill down into the
different pieces to see what's going on
in those pieces and that's quite nice so
it's not something you can do with
networks that are defined in other
frameworks at least as easily as you and
straightforwardly as you can hear but
the downside is that things that are
conceptually quite simple can be quite
kind of tedious to express in this kind
of graphical way here were you defining
individual vertices that correspond to
operations and the edges that connect up
to operations and it's it's kind of like
you did having to compile a sort of
technical computer science jargon way of
describing it is easy having to to take
a take some code and do the the
translation to static single assignment
form yourself and that's not ideal it
served us well so far but we think we
can do better and certainly other
frameworks do do better and the way that
we would do better is by making it
appear that you're writing ordinary
Mathematica code and then we would
translate this code into something very
similar to the graph that you see here
so the underlying idea that I'm showing
here which is root-mean-square
difference between two tensors you can
exert me express it with an EDD graph
but it's clearer if you just write
directly that was the the difference the
mean and the square I think I left off
the power probe to you here good
that's not important for example um this
is the function this is the feature that
we call net function and function
actually plays several different roles
one of them will be to make it easier to
define net graphs initially but it also
will have potentially have a are the
rules that I'll talk about it in a
little bit so very similar to that is
the idea of custom layers this is when
for whatever reason the underlying
framework which is our cases is MX net
but you don't really have to know that
that the underlying framework is
incapable of expressing the computation
that you need for your network we hope
that that's not often the case but when
it is you might need to resort to
quoting something in in C++ or C or
Mathematica and we want to make it tall
to do that but hopefully that's that
that won't come up as often as as and it
won't come very often a feature that is
also very important and this is
something it's much bigger than just the
neural network framework is the numeric
array feature and this is something that
um we in a sort of a lot of discussion
during on the company right notice that
make this happen for the next version of
Mathematica basically we we want to make
numeric dense numeric arrays of
arbitrary rank a sort of first level
part of the like first-class part of the
language and that means that the
approach that's we've been using so far
which is that kind of lists of Lists are
ways that you express americ matrices
well will somewhat be superseded by a
new construct that called the AmeriCorps
a and America way
array will allow you to kind of
guarantee that you've got efficient
representation of potentially quite a
large numeric tensors and easily see
what their rank are so currently this
of Lists scheme it gives us the ability
to to get a lot of efficiency it out of
the time so here's an example we range
will produce what appears to be an
ordinary list but underneath it is a
efficient factory and you can see it
takes a hundred eighty four bytes to
represent this array but if you
construct that list a different way just
by typing it in manually it still
behaves the same but it's not actually
so a contiguous chunk of memory and that
means that it's it's slower to do things
like matrix so linear algebra on it and
it's it's certainly larger a memory you
can see it's 280 versus 184 bytes and
numeric array will kind of do away with
this distinction you know if a numeric
arrays is there then it's it's packed
possible by definition and we'll use
these numeric arrays to to represent the
weights and the inputs and outputs of
your networks that will be your networks
will be one of the one of the kind of
premier consumers of these numeric
arrays in Mathematica 12 if all goes
according to plan one other important
feature that I've never didn't mention
explicitly is that you'll be able to see
the dimensions easily that's not
something that you can see of full water
impact arrays lists of lists it's very
hard to tell what this is this object
but if it's in if it's kind of
encapsulated in a numeric array it's
very straightforward to see um let me
I'll have to probably skip over a little
bit because I'm how am i doing for time
I'm is it a hard limit at 8:30
what can I talk a bit more you can even
talk for a bit longer
great cool so flexibility of course as I
mentioned earlier that's the ability of
our framework to to model new and
interesting techniques as they come up
and there's certainly some kinds of
networks that we can't directly model
today and we hope to plug most of that
gap by just introducing the appropriate
layers which don't you exist
some of these layers are essential
things like extract Li and odd max there
look up particular positions in a tensor
using another tensor and this one
produces positions of the maximum
components of a tensor these things you
can't do them any other way at the
moment but there are the layers that we
think should exist just because they're
kind of somewhat tedious to implement as
net graphs that's certainly part of the
the flexibility picture another
important part is making sure that our
higher order if functional style
operators become more flexible so net
map operators one of these it's a
crucial one and what it basically does
is it takes another layer or sub network
and applies it repeatedly to a higher
rank tensor so for example if we have a
linear layer that operates on just using
example it operates on vectors and
produces objectives you can see it
operates on a vector of size 3
introduces a vector of size 3 in a net
map operator of that linear layer will
operate on a matrix that's n by 3 and
produces a matrix a 10 by 3 and it just
does that by repeating this operation on
each of the N of rows of that matrix
that's very useful it's used all over
the place especially in domains that
have a some notion of time like audio or
NLP text processing but where this falls
down a bit is that we we can't I'm sorry
just close that quickly
where this full style bit is that if you
have a layer that has more than one
input then you can't put you can't put
it in an implant operator so we want to
fix that
and ideally net map operator will just
look at the inputs and and see the
different look at the network you gave
it see the different inputs and it'll
produce a higher-order network that just
naturally adds an end to all of the
dimensions of the inputs and outputs of
that that later that you that you gave
it
and it will in fact be a little bit more
flexible than that so you can choose to
broadcast some of those and map others
there's a very similar story for net
fault operator this is a this alone will
be kind of unlock a whole family of
different kinds of network that we can't
currently Express let me skip the
dynamic valuation thing because I think
those you know what that is will sort of
know immediately and there's not much
time left to explain it let me talk
about the last major sort of future
feature that we we think is super
important for the future of our
framework and that is interoperating
with other frameworks and for the
purposes of that we already do offer
something we offer the MX net format so
you can open this this page and you'll
see this is a format we've had since it
takes is one version ago this lets you
import and export from MX nets file
based format which is a mixture of two
different files a JSON file that stores
that intro topology in a params file
that stores the weights the things that
aren't ideal about that though it's
quite low level it's quite a lot more
low-level than our framework and that
has various implications it means that
it's very hard to import certain kinds
of complex net because by the time
they've been expressed in MX net they
kind of all them all the little
components that that you use to build
something like an LS TM it's very hard
to recognize those and put them back
together into an LS TM so we can't
import certain kinds of net or at least
if we do import them they won't be very
useful you can export them of course but
then sort of similar problem happens
which is that whoever's using your
network they're kind of stuck with
various choices that you made so if
you're exporting a a sequence network
like an LS TM and it operates on a
specific size specific length then
whoever receives that network will only
ever be able to operate on that length
they don't have a variable length
representation of the original network
so the solution that
that we see at the moment the kind of
most promising one is a format called
annex onyx it's a format that's
supported by a variety of other
frameworks you can see here they're also
converters that that convert between
frameworks that don't directly support
it these converters aren't necessarily
completely fully featured but they
certainly do support some serious use
cases like image processing and most
importantly their variety of device
manufacturers that want to introduce
hardware platforms or or ad driver
support for its the existing hardware
that that will natively understand the
onyx format and that means that you know
while at the moment you can't target
training on AMD cards onyx provides a
the possibility that in future you might
be able to export a net from an awful
language and then train hit in some in
some form using tools provided by AMD
and also to do things like run run nets
that you've trained on on in the Wolfram
language efficiently on mobile platforms
that run on chips like arm and so on so
yeah that's the kind of summary of where
we want to go in the feet in the future
there's a lot here we may not get to all
of us that we're also very keen to hear
from you which of these features you
most excited about or most interested in
let me maybe end there there I think we
will be
to answer questions but I'm not 100%
sure about that yes we will we're gonna
we're going to conclude the the live
presentations for this we hope everyone
enjoyed the talks and learned about
concepts and tools that you'll find
useful in creating your own neural
network models we will be sending an
email to everyone in today's audience
with a link to the webinar recording as
well as notebook links we look forward
to seeing you all on May 9th for the
second webinar in the series that's when
our topic will be image processing with
deep neural nets we will send out a
reminder about this session as well I
would also just want to point out that
we have a data science webinar series
that starts one week from today we'll
put a link in the in the chat here that
link will also be found on the Wolfram u
website and included in the webinar
survey that will appear immediately
following the session we do appreciate
your feedback and we use the survey
results to guide us and making
improvements in the Wolfram technology
stack and adding the feature is most
important to our user community alright
we'll keep it open for a few more
minutes so that Talia and Sebastian can
answer questions in the chat pane unless
either one of you want to mic up for
another minute or so other than that
thank you guys again for coming in we'll
see you next time